among over 11 600 U.S employees women
were less satisfied with their jobs when
they reported to a female boss whereas
men showed no difference in job
satisfaction based on their supervisors
gender
why do you think that is
so I think this goes back to the
challenges faced by our female ancestors
throughout human history a larger
percentage of social groups were Patra
local meaning that when women were
married they left their families to go
live with their husbands and so this
would have been particularly challenging
for ancestral women because they are
surrounded by individuals with whom they
weren't genetically related and we know
that it's harder to form Cooperative
relationships with non-kin compared to
Kin and so I've thought about okay well
how might women have navigated these
relationships how might they have
recruited allies in these contexts and
Dave Geary has made the argument that
one way women might have formed
Cooperative Bonds in these contexts is
through either reciprocal altruism or
mutualism so meaning they're forming
relationships based on shared goals or
exchanging benefits in a tit-for-tat
manner and so if you look at what are
the contexts that allow those types of
relationships to succeed it tends to be
when relationship Partners have
symmetrical levels of power and
resources and so I think one way to
think about this might be what would it
look like if say there was a huge
asymmetry in resources between partners
so say a famous celebrity tried to form
a Cooperative relationship with an
unhoused person or a homeless person
this would be very challenging because
they it would be quite unlikely that
they'd have mutually aligned goals and
over time you would expect that this
relationship would devolve into either
um
kind of exploitation or just kind of you
know a unilateral extraction of
resources so leeching on another
person's resources and indeed that's
what mathematicals find is that when
Partners diverge in power and resources
The Cooperative bonds kind of
um they're no longer mutually beneficial
it's one partner taking advantage of the
other partner and so if these are the
conditions that uphold reciprocal
altruism what I suspect is that women
throughout human history upheld their
reciprocal bonds with unrelated same-sex
women under such conditions such that
they preferred contacts where they were
of equal power and equal resources and
too strong of deviations would have led
to conflict and kind of corroded the
relationship and so I think that this
can become problematic in modern context
where there are clear demarcations in
status and resources or in contact say
where we have social media and we could
observe the lives of people who deviate
strongly from us and their social
conditions that basically these
deviations might be more corrosive to
women's same-sex relationships if
throughout human history our female
ancestors were forming Cooperative bonds
with one another under conditions of
symmetry why is that not the same case
for men
so great question throughout human
history our male ancestors were more
often involved in coalitionary contexts
so they were forming larger groups both
for the context of hunting but also I
think more consequentially for the
context of warfare and so when you form
these large groups
um there tends to be especially in
Warfare there's an advantage to having
larger numbers so a numerical Advantage
so having more men kind of on your team
is advantageous and so in these contexts
what helps is a strong hierarchy this is
really useful for organizing large
groups and it's really helpful for kind
of a chain of command to organize and
attack so if every man out on the
battlefield is kind of going with his
own whims that is really uncoordinated
so if we think of a modern context of
warfare I think the one example might be
football kind of an analog there is a
clear line of command in which there's
the coach and then maybe the quarterback
reads the plays and everyone knows what
the game plan is and that leads to
success on the field so too is the case
in Warfare where you need a strong chain
of command to organize the attack and so
you also need Beyond just a chain of
command you also need specialization so
not every man is going to be equally
talented in every role so maybe there's
one guy who's great at throwing the
spears one guy who's great at making the
spears one guy who's great at kind of
coming up with the strategy and so
having these this role specialization is
really useful for large groups because
then you can maximize your talent and so
if men throughout human history were
more often in competing in these group
based contexts then they stood to gain
from asymmetries and power insofar as
that meant their group was going to be
more organized and cohesive and
successful on the battlefield and so I
think this group component is really
important because what that meant is
that for our male ancestors if they were
successful they all lived and the
genetic data suggests they reproduced
with the local women which is not you
know Pleasant to think about but that's
what the evidence suggests and so there
are reproductive benefits but also just
survival and then for the men who lost
it wasn't just losing a football match
it was death you got slaughtered
potentially the people back home got
slaughtered so there was a lot on the
line and so what that meant is men stood
to gain if there were asymmetries in
power that led to success on the
battlefield likewise they stood to gain
by having same-sex peers on their team
who may have been more talented and who
may have been rewarded with status so if
you were on a football team and your
quarterback is phenomenal and he gets
more status than you do you might still
be happy because your team wins as a
whole even if he is relatively better
off there's a trickle-down effect of his
his ability to help you and because men
it seems were more coalitional that
benefits everybody overall in terms of
Bible and reproduction whereas with
women it seems like they didn't need
this coalitional thing so much you would
have had women presumably competing some
a little bit of polygyny perhaps going
on so you'd have had co-wives of one
particular person you would have had all
of the concerns you have around child
rearing Joyce beninson was on the show a
little while ago and obviously she's
done that great work to do with uh
tennis but she's studying tennis players
at the moment have you seen this most
recent stuff so she's moved on from
female sports teams and she's now
obsessing over tennis players and she's
looking at what happens after a match
between male male and female female
tennis players the amount of physical
contact that they have the sort of body
language the kind of words that they use
presumably to describe how the match
went and you'll be familiar with the
work that she's done but for the people
that aren't
um it seems like in sports teams
men who compete against other male teams
that compete against other male teams
show both more cohesion within the
competition itself amongst their own
team and then once the game's over
they're more happy to be uh physically
and sort of verbally
um collaborative and and complementary
with the uh opponents females during
sports games seem to show both more
disdain for their own side and for the
other side as well like they're just not
really friends with anybody at all
what's happening people if you enjoyed
that then press here for the full
unedited episode and don't forget to
subscribe
face
[Music]